gorgeous that place is massive look all
those rooms for yes finally somewhere
nice to stay I feel sorry for the crappy
motel next door I'm amazed that place is
still open right next to a big hotel
either my god
[Music]
Wow people cars must be a car show up Oh
No somebody having your laugh Hotel hell
laddies 9 the [ __ ] can't spell part-time
housekeeper
I can't leave anything worse Stamper
ties on the outside of your hotel
[Music]
morning good morning and first name is
Vanessa Vanessa that's it I'm gone
I see you're having a classic car show
today no those all belong to our owner
Philip no stop
they do they belong to the owner
what's with the plate that's like Hotel
hell on one of the plates yes he did
that for me Jeff Dougy employer the
month 2010 you know it's 2013 I do yes
other staff that bad there hasn't been a
more recent employee than month
last I heard actually he was in jail
holy crap we have so many great
employees it's ridiculous that we're not
recognized more than we are here's your
card and here is your room code you're
in room 220 we show me the way home
oh sure if you'd like shall we please
follow me I'll do that we're gonna sighs
yes okay just across here so you have to
go out to get back up again yes right
here this is not the hotel this is our
north wing motel now why in the [ __ ]
would I want to stay in there all we
have available to rent in the hotel are
four Suites I'd rather stay in their
next tour okay
funding this dump I'm sorry people want
to stay in the hotel they don't want to
stay in the Crackerbox driving up yeah I
didn't expect to be put in a motel no I
understand and I am sorry
all right it's just right over here
thank you you're welcome
let see how a sophist hideous who would
use it [ __ ] brown sofa like that oh
my god it gets worse in here as bad as
this aunty I know the rooms are
furnished completely with a staff room
Philip and Ginger's home oh dear there's
a mattress on the house yes
you bring a mattress from your house
into your hotel I wouldn't they charge
$250 a night for that mattress I don't
even know what to say about it when they
get new stuff they bring old stuff here
there's some storage rooms that are
furniture where the storage places well
jeez
it's like a suite just for a creme it's
like a dumping ground there's more to
Wow you are kidding me
not Oh Mike your heart look at this it
was like a whole duck just junk
everywhere I don't understand the hotel
owner that would dump half a [ __ ] in
hotel rooms and not rent them out
Gordon was pretty appalled at the state
of the storage rooms how much crap there
was and they're just a big [ __ ] waste
I appreciate it thank you wow this place
is so disappointing